here now with the latest Fox News
contributors Charlie hurt and Miranda
Devine Charlie Miranda thanks for being
with us tonight Miranda let me start
with you
Comer wants to see a document the FBI
has that isn't classified but they're
saying he can't see it even though he
has a legal right to uh will he see it
can the FBI Stonewall how do these
things normally play out you follow
these things closely
well of course they're just going to
continue to Stonewall they've already
defied a subpoena it's been two weeks
since it was issued Christopher Ray is
uh just showing himself to be a cover-up
Merchant that's what he did from the
minute he took over from James Comey
another cover-up Merchant and this is
the problem there is no accountability
the the FBI and the FBI director
Christopher Ray know that the Attorney
General Merit Garland is backing them
they know that there are no consequences
for them and so of course they can
afford to Stonewall and Merit Garland
who's quite happy to Jail uh former
Trump officials who defied subpoenas
from the January 6 committee treats
Republican subpoenas like a joke this is
the doj corrupt and it's in your face
Charlie we know the the administration
counts on the warm blanket of the Legacy
Media of the left-wing media not to
cover the obvious blatant corruption
right in front of them but how much how
worried do you think if you're in the
doj if you're in the white house if
you're a part of the Biden family and
this is out there it's something's going
to pop to the surface eventually does
this change any of their calculation as
to how they play this
you would think that it would but
honestly the the media has been so uh
uncurious about any of this uh that that
they probably are uh you know feel
pretty comfortable that they can get
away with it if it weren't for people
like Miranda and a select few other
people in the Press who've been bird
dogging this story from the very
beginning we wouldn't know anything you
know if we haven't learned anything else
over the last couple of years we've
learned that that the FBI is Thoroughly
corrupt to the core it is it is uh
entire at least the part of it that's
operating out of Washington uh it is
entirely engaged in politics it views
its purpose to uh to to to put their
thumb on the scale of Elections and uh
and then of course we also see they're
also interested uh probably first and
foremost in protecting themselves which
is why you can get somebody like
Christopher Wray you could just plop
anybody into that spot it seems like and
their first instinct is to figure out
how to protect the FBI and we saw the
same thing of course with the Mueller
report we now realize the degree to
which the Mueller the Mueller team
didn't even ask the all of the people
who were involved uh in the
investigation they were doing because
they wanted to protect them and uh and
and you know it's as disgusting as all
of it is you you would think that with a
vibrant free press that we you know you
could you would have a lot of people
eager to fill in the blanks here but
that's just not happening because the
Press is as in bed with the FBI and the
federal government as they all are
Miranda hypotheticals can be overdone
but sometimes they're useful I think the
media has held out with one excuse that
this is just a hunter thing this is a
family thing it's not a Joe thing let's
say whether it's this five million
dollars or some direct verifiable
undeniable connection is made between
the business dealings of Hunter Biden
and the political connections and the
beneficiary meaning Joe Biden we've got
the receipts right here the money went
to him a deal was made Comer's saying
maybe a bribery scheme let's say a
Smoking Gun really does develop Miranda
would
I hate to ask the question but even then
would they acknowledge it or are they
that much is it that much of a hatchet
job
look I think you are saying in the risks
that the doj and the FBI are taking to
cover up whatever evidence it is that
they have regarding these allegations
against Joe Biden regarding the hunter
Biden investigation you can see that
whatever it is they're covering up is
pretty damaging it must be explosive and
I think the good news is that we have
all these whistleblowers coming forward
uh Men of Integrity who have you know
sacrificed their careers their
livelihood their reputations their
families happiness really
um and for for for an ideal because
they're Patriots because they see as you
saw the IRS whistleblower the other day
went on CBS and explained that he
couldn't live with his conscience unless
he spoke up so that's a good thing this
is a fight really between good and evil
these good men and the evil of that
corrupt culture in the FBI and that's
also infiltrated the doj and I guess
it's been there for a long time
yeah uh Charlie Miranda mentions the IRS
whistleblower who if you watch the
interview I'm sure you've seen at least
parts of it uh Israel locked in uh it
seems like a guy who wanted to do his
job and was told do it this way which
was not the way they've done it in the
past and it's clear because it's the
president's son it's a different
situation always benefiting him uh do
you think again that the firing of IRS
workers that team that was looking 100
fighting I mean can you just Shuffle to
a new team to cover it up or at some
point uh can sunlight be shown on it
well I mean they have they've
demonstrated that they have an endless
supply of cover-up teams in the FBI or
in the federal government at the IRS
because every single one of these cases
that we that we sort of know about
through the veil uh because that you
know they tend to operate in secrecy for
these investigations which is
understandable but but every single one
of them when you you know you get on
down the road that's why I mentioned the
the Mueller uh investigation because you
get on down the road and you find out
that they don't even interview the top
principals who made the decisions and
the same and it appears that's the exact
same thing that's going on here with the
the IRS investigation into to uh into
Hunter Biden and um and and you know the
other thing is uh you know another level
of corruption that's going on here is at
the level of elected officials you know
you can you maybe you don't like Chuck
Grassley for his political opinions but
nobody would ever say that Chuck
Grassley has ever no I you couldn't find
a reporter who could tell you that Chuck
Grassley has ever lied to them about
something whereas we've just been
through five years of all of us Democrat
voters everybody being lied to by all
these Democrats Inc elected officials
who were supposed to be the last line of
defense protecting citizens from a
runaway federal government they're
they're lying on behalf of them and
doing what they can to protect this
government against the Citizens and
that's really messed up and I you know I
don't know what the answer is we I don't
know how we get to a better place but
this is nuts
it's not there are lies there are damn
lies and then there's the Biden doj
right now and what they're willing to do
across the Spectrum to cover up for the
big guy Charlie hurt Miranda Devine
thank you both for joining us hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else